bene attenti ragazzi e quindi siamo
tornati all'ora qui perché
effettivamente arson ogni tot fa uscire
l'espansione nuova e noi non ce ne
priviamo oggi ragazzi sono con stefano
proviamo a fare a sfidarci vista
l'uscita espansione variar sono ormai un
rituale non ci spieghiamo quando esce il
6 nuova comprende 135 nuovissime carte
c'è una nuova classe che il cacciatore
di demoni che io ho sbloccato prima
perché per sfruttarlo devi fare un
avventura che l'ho già fatta
le leggendarie supreme o supreme caso
poi non ci saranno più duplicati delle
carte per ogni livello di larita ha
raggiunto damon inibiti c'è un mazzo
gratis per chi non ha mai giocato ma
anche per i veterani e inoltre hanno
aggiornato il sacerdote ma in tutto
questo ragazzi io sfidano stefano
utilizzando la nuova classe che il
cacciatore di demoni e vediamo cosa esce
fuori ma prima spostamento carte allora
ragazzi prima carta vediamo del sonno
vanta 90 pacchetti nuovi quindi vediamo
la che devo farne le carte nuova zona
che cacchio di abbiamo pacchetto niente
leggendaria sarebbe stato veramente
strano riguardo poi tutte dopo per
adesso il commento solo se trovo epiche
o leggendarie tipo questa sarebbe
favorita buono ok ho sbloccato godzilla
infligge 30 anni e un servitore nemico
se muore ripete l'effetto sul solito
arca vaccari che gli attacchi dei suoi
servitori e del tuo eroe ignorano pro
porca vacca che rush bellissimo bora
gioielliere oscuro a najar che un po
thanos dopo che hai giocato un segreto
rin vieni un segreto di un'altra classe
male solo che non mi piace il ladro
ragazzi come classe quindi non credo la
userò cioè non lo so adesso vediamo però
non è la madonna che culo dixon grande
predatore assalto run torino alte vette
gx supremo nel tuo mazzo chissà come mix
supremo specchio dell'anima peccato che
giocano step da mali adrin gray
battaglia ammette nella tua mano una
copia di ogni magia che hai lanciato su
tweet su twitter
in questa partita non capiscono niente
delle leggendarie che sto trovando però
vabbè far kutcher fermi che culo anche
stavolta di fila c'è la rende ovviamente
solo dei leggendari di fila trovo
speriamo che non perderà la catena sono
tutte leggendari adesso invece da lo
sapevo tre leggendari di fila rega
incredibile baluardo di asino quando che
ormai dovrebbe subire danni quest'arma
perde invece uno di integrità bellissimo
praticamente il tuo eroe è immune per
quattro turni
porcaccia vacca e fortissima salme è
veramente incredibile quarta leggendaria
di fila affinché la predizione prof
tre di fila non era mai successo regala
tre leggendari di fila vi giuro non mi
era mai successo
oddio ma perché è che culo oggi no vabbè
ragazzo spacchettamenti incredibile
mette a cava supremo nel tuo pazzo e
siamo arrivati all'ultimo mamma mia
ragazzi spacchettamento incredibile ho
trovato un sacco di leggendarie in 90
pacchetti tipo 6 o 7 6
tutti i servitori subiscono danni
doppione faceva ma ora il momento di
fare il massimo e di combattere contro
step nick clegg com
ok ora si ragiona hakama furtivi taranto
di morte mette hakama supremo nel tuo
mazzo questo il figo avrà il ladro è non
so devo ancora decidere classe fare a
bossi che si ragiona ragazzi
gustiamoci da questa leggendaria astro
mante solari più uno danni magici che
buonissimo che il mago rantolo di morte
mette solari al suprema nel tuo mazzo
adesso sono in decisissimo su quale
classe utilizzare mago ladro cacciatore
di demoni non lo so voglio concludere
con un'altra leggendaria gioco mi fido
di te l'abbiamo ancora sette pacchetti a
disposizione me ne devi dare un'altra
cosa migliore che ho io chi male dico tu
possiede rai dentro una leggendaria me
lo sento
un'epica va bene maledizione ha
funzionato in parte minore che mancano
da bustine da mimmo il coser i
fichissimi pubblico un'altra epica ma
allora ci siamo così vicini fermi però
un'arma del cacciatore di demoni dopo
che il tuo eroe attaccato un servitore
può attaccare nuovamente attacco due
volte all'ora signore e signori è il
momento di utilizzarlo psicopompo ma
quello ma dai ma va a cagare tra tutti
non proprio quello che volevo usare o
esatto ma dai che sfiga ma è quel così
no tu la mia rinascita
se non ho mica visto io io devo fa così
o per forza per aveva organizzato tutto
va dato merito e di vita a tutti sonora
un casino
la carta è fighissimo vai guardia
guardiano ceco guarda tre carte il tuo
mazzo scegliere una e la mette in cima
quindi alla prossima che pesca se questa
bellissima altro è veramente finita la
cosa più vicina ad un ragno che abbia
mai visto di bruttezza dico che faceva
ca nun o forse questa nave utilizzata
presidenziali cosi brutti ok allora
fanini cosa è se però con la mary
veramente spaccare immediatamente più
perso ma come emerso non ho più vita ho
capito ma guardami allora addio
santissimo
16 a 14 ok poi potresti non avere
un'altra di quelli che fa danno a tutti
potresti non parla infatti non ce l'ho
però aspetta un secondo una volta
potresti non avercela ok teoricamente
questo voce agli spettatori aspetta e si
rafforza ha fatto forse ha fatto una
cazzata va bene ok
secondo me siamo messi sono messo peggio
io però va beh con queste buona figura
devo perdere il 3 1 chissenefrega
il pc ignaccolo è veramente brutto
sì ma se ha diritto deve veramente
uscire una roba seria altro pezzo dai
gioco si dalla mia parte
grazie sei pescato la l'apiro sfera o
mio dio
la metamorfosi demoniache il credito e
ho perso mia vita non ci credo a un
addio da pino sfera te prego non è in
mano non è ovviamente no
però finisce per giungere la tua con una
palla con una piro sfera a metà va bene
ma mai alla morte nel senso di mannaia
al drago di ars non lo so usare io e
cacciatori demoni però speriamo di fare
una roba decente e al poi molto fisici e
si intuisce dalle tre leggi le carte
diciamo che molte hanno il potere che se
sono sull'estrema sinistro sull'esterno
a destra si attivano due cose diverse
invece che una sola è quella roba il
rinelli ripudio però madonna per forza
nonno così erano niente perché ma sento
che tra poco devo iniziare preoccuparmi
no no era già ragionando così
così è allora ma funzioni brutto per
dentro o cercare di capire come usare
questa questa carta cioè processo
iniziato a due ore però eccolo qua la
leggendaria che ho trovato prima la cama
ha chiamato moreno ecco davvero curiosi
vedere come dopo scopriamo la sera
appena finisce nel mazzo
noi facciamo così vai 13 di vita modo
pescare leroy ce l'hai o come lo rivano
puoi averlo dai mari di mano nel mazzo
maledizione se nella collezione
chi lo sa non uso questa perché vorrei
usarla dopo però
stiamo andando lì sgoccioli rega
sgocciola punto dunque sarà ma che puoi
suonare i piedi della all'altro della
mappa
allora abbiamo lo stesso sfondo e se
provare questo o venivano succede fra i
giornali e rinascita dare in hd nascevo
1 pensavamo che era più tardi nuove
realtà o sbaglia ma mia non è male
facciamo così not to face
e questo aggeggio costa solo due ma
quello che diciamo capital
ok questo ha dovuto fare tutta
l'avventura per sbloccare me lo è credo
che qui la situazione si mette male
sempre peggio vabbè e vabbè allora
uccidi melo poverino questo quadro nero
toglierti altro e se il prima possibile
paura ti attacco perché ci ho paura di
sai già 17 siamo pari ma ho paura tv che
cosa c'è in mano quindi attacco perché
secondo me quindi c'è poco di vita per
loro così come si chiama le era adesso
direi che può bastare va bene vediamo
allora se avrei dovuto fare anche questo
però volevo farlo più figo avrai sheikh
il calca sigilli è nevicato su faremo
nel mazzo aspetta che qua un casino 16
una di quelle cosine 21 questa carta mi
sembra incredibile poi magari è quella
confiscato io prima 10 da anni questo si
ride novità questa cosa volevo usare da
due ore ma costa tantissimo però è anche
vero che è dormiente quindi io ho ancora
vivo acam tra due turni nel senso che
questo è già uno e poi il mio si
svegliano il prossimo turno va 1
ok poi fai 10 danni è infatti è molto
buona nostra carta cioè mi secondo me
potrebbe essere leggendaria
tranquillamente invece lei neanche pinga
e rara io non so come andrà a finire
questa partita madonna stop verde no è
veramente di firma poi scusami ma sto
kat
guarda che si sveglia sto qua il turno è
di 6 2
ok non so con non so contare non ho
voglia di contare asso di bastoni niente
voglia di contare so se bastano madonna
bastano ma basta boia le combo normale
non
gigi gigi buffon gigi dove non è stata
per niente facile bravo molto bella si è
niente basta questa era l'espansione
molto [ __ ] molto difficile per scaricare
i demoni è fighissimo e molto fico si si
si
niente è passata da careri stefano che
c'è in descrizione fatemi sapere se la
provate se vi piace qualcosa
vabbè ci ha proseguito ragazzi ciao
[Musica]